[Music]
if you had told me that i wouldn't
finish and post this final video from
europe until 2022
i'm not sure i would have believed you
but here we are
lately my drive to create has been lower
than usual that tends to happen every
year around the holidays i just want to
relax and unwind and shove everything
work-related into a dark corner until
the new year rolls in and everything
feels fresh again
when i finally did sit down to sort
through this footage it felt like i was
experiencing the trip for a second time
which left me dreaming of the italian
dolomites all over again
this is our home for the next five days
in cortina italy
here's our kitchen
we got
a bathroom down here bedroom down here
here we have our resident italian
bathroom
here's one bedroom
there's another one
and here is the master bedroom
nice and spacious
[Music]
[Music]
what are we hiking allie the trade she
may loop trade
i appreciate you
before becoming a photographer i worked
overseas for abercrombie and fitch i
studied and worked in milan and london
with the company before relocating to
south italy as the international general
manager of a hollister store in campagna
i was 26 years old and i was responsible
for 200 italians and one american store
manager it was a position that pushed me
in every kind of way learning the
language leading a large team meeting
sales goals hiring recruiting
learning how to drive like an italian
learning how to live like one
it was a year and a half of extreme
highs and extreme lows
[Music]
[Music]
this is my hot water
from my faucet
full steam
and actually it's freezing cold and i
even have a shower running because
that's the only way to get lukewarm
water
i spent most of my time inside the store
i was managing and there were good times
for sure
i loved the people i was working with
but by the time six months had gone by i
hated going to that job from the moment
i parked my car and began walking into
the mall i felt dread i had no life
outside of work and i spent my days
dreaming of escaping far away into the
mountains to the sea
all the beauty around me that was italy
sometimes i would leave work and drive
straight to the amalfi house for a solo
sunset hike the santiago de day was my
favorite trail out there it was the one
single thing in my life at that time
that helped me recharge and escape the
ever-present home of naples
one day after work i left my house for
ikea which was pretty much a 20 minute
drive
but when i reached the exit i just kept
driving i drove six hours to san
giovanni and then boarded a ferry to
sicily i didn't have anything with me
apart from my purse i booked a hotel
woke up the next day and drove around
the coast and then all the way back to
naples just in time for work and that
was the beginning of the end for me i
realized that i just couldn't keep doing
what i was doing i had to get out of
that job and out into the world and so i
did which is a whole another story but
it ends like this being back in italy 10
years later exploring this beautiful
country on my own terms working for
myself camera in hand and earning far
more than i ever did back then and yeah
a lot had to happen between then and now
but here's what i know if you aren't
happy start taking small steps skip your
usual exit start writing out your dreams
little by little just spoon feed your
curiosity because you just never know
where it might lead
[Music]
won't rest until i make it right
couldn't stand the thought of losing
[Music]
in the dark
[Music]
so you can make it up
[Music]
a little bit
[Music]
wow this is crazy apparently we're in a
world war one
trench
and
cave
with the window fortification and wild
it's a mountain dwarf a mountain this
whole mountain is pretty much a big ant
hill of trenches
just went through that doorway now we're
gonna go into this dark tunnel we have
no idea where this goes so let's find
out
oh it's very dark what it's very dark oh
you coming wow yeah we're coming okay i
get claustrophobic
it's very dark
wow
[Music]
[Music]
all right
this is the last part before the summit
wow
we're almost at the top here
what do you think this way
such a maze
more ladders
[Applause]
wow
this is so crazy
we made it
because
we made it
up to the top
this light's incredible
so pretty
you we did it
[Music]
he
wow
um
yeah it's handwritten so it's a little
bit hard to read how are we feeling
about our last hike here so beautiful
so much wow there are tunnels there are
tunnels and there are windows and rooms
and
castles and
high uh elevation ladders
and now we're going to go eat pasta yes
the best pasta of the trip
pasta posta a pasta
[Music]
here we go another border crossing and
we don't know what we're going to let us
in
[Music]
getting
we're in zurich but we have to go get
kova test in order to get on the plane
and get back into the u.s
wow thank you sir i just cut you off
this is my first covent test
ever
hello hello
we're live we're live so we're just
waiting for our results now and yeah
hopefully we're all negative so we can
fly home tomorrow oh feel free
go into america
okay i
oh
[Music]
what time is it
too early
what time is it
[Music]
so that was europe three epic weeks in
switzerland and italy and by far the
longest amount of time i've ever been
away from the van
as much as i love to travel it's always
so good to be home
if you guys saw my last video then you
know i headed south to big sur to chase
the warmer weather and after a month on
the coast i began the journey east
toward the sierras and the southwest
desert
which is where i'll meet you next time
so thanks for being here and i'll see
you out on that open road
[Music]
we are at this lake and it's super muddy
look at how much
mud we have on our shoes
this is ridiculous oh my god it won't
come off
oh it's really pretty though
what a view